staying with the pandemic now and the
last few months have seen a worrying
rise in the rates of pregnant women
hospitalized with covid19 new data from
the united kingdom shows that one in six
of the most critically ill patients are
unvaccinated expectant mothers
inoculation rates among mothers-to-be
remain low with conflicting information
fueling fears
uk resident kelsey routes was 29 weeks
pregnant when she got sick with covid19
doctors induced a coma and when she woke
her son had already been delivered she
hadn't gotten the coronavirus vaccine
if anyone was told that they would be
put into a coma and potentially dying i
think you'd probably consider it a lot
more um
but yeah i think i'm going to get it now
the uk's national health service says
unvaccinated pregnant women now
represent one in six hospitalizations
due to covet 19.
claire bromley was also hospitalized
with the virus and told she might have
to deliver her baby via c-section at
only 26 weeks a dangerously premature
age for delivery one that can carry
long-term consequences
i thought i was gonna die and i thought
he was
gonna die and we waited so long for this
family that that was the greatest fear
that
my husband was gonna lose us both
now that they are both safely out of the
hospital she's urging other expectant
moms to protect themselves against the
virus
pregnancy can be a confusing time with
an abundance of opposing advice
guidelines around the coronavirus
vaccines have been no different
with some countries recommending the
shots for moms to be and others advising
against them
that's partially because pregnant women
were excluded from vaccine trials as is
standard practice for most medicines
now a growing body of data shows the
benefits outweigh the risks for
expectant mothers
there is a risk that you may get a more
serious form of that covid you may be
admitted to the hospital you can have
the vaccine at any stage during
pregnancy i've got increasing amount of
data that tells us that it does not
increase the risk of miscarriage it does
not increase the risk of stillbirth
with the failure of medical science to
send a clear message to pregnant women
there are growing calls for them to be
included in the future of vaccine
research
we're joined now by dr bergie testrizzak
who's with us now she's the head of the
birthing center at the university
hospital bond here in germany dr srizak
thank you for taking the time to speak
to dw
hello good morning
now the general consensus the general
medical consensus is that pregnant
people should get vaccinated explain to
us why this is the advice being given to
patients
we have seen from the beginning of the
pandemic that
if pregnant women get covered they have
a higher risk of getting seriously ill
and this has been
even more pronounced during the last
delta surge so within the last couple of
months we have seen more and more
severely ill patients that had to go to
the icu had to be ventilated and
this has very high risk for mothers and
babies so it's very important and we
advise all women who want to get
pregnant are pregnant or breastfeeding
to get vaccinated as soon as possible
i suppose some people might wonder why
are pregnant women at greater risk than
perhaps the rest of the general public
of getting seriously ill when they were
to contract coronavirus
we really don't know why that is so and
why the the delta variant of the virus
um makes this risk even higher um and it
does have to do a little bit with risk
factors so if you're an older mother or
severely obese or you already have
a lung disease you're an even greater
risk but just being pregnant especially
in the last trimester
more than doubles the risk to get
seriously ill
and that's why it's so important to
prevent the severe illnesses and that's
what the vaccine has been shown um to do
and it's we have more data now we have a
lot of data actually that it's safe to
get the vaccination during pregnancy and
then are all vaccines suitable for
pregnant women
at the moment we have the most data for
the mrna
vaccine so that would be
pfizer
biontech moderna
and that's why they are recommended in
pregnancy we don't have uh
much data on the other vaccines
now perhaps the biggest concern some
have is how will the vaccine impact the
baby the unborn child what do you say to
your patients who come in and say i'm
actually really nervous about getting
the vaccine and how do you ease their
fears
we get those questions a lot and what we
see is that if the mother gets seriously
ill that is a also very high risk for
the baby to be born prematurely um or
even dying during pregnancy and so it's
it's important that the mother's death
stays healthy and we do have a lot of
data that
in the pregnancy the vaccine is not
dangerous for mothers or babies
now there is a lot of fear and confusion
you know that better than anyone being a
doctor yourself what needs to be done to
get the message message that's backed by
science across to the people
um
we we
get those questions a lot and it's very
difficult but i think it's it's
important that in germany um for example
stico now has recommended um the
vaccination for pregnant women as have
many
other countries and i think this will
help
to inform patients and to get the
message across why it is so important
and it's safe to get vaccinated in
pregnancy dr brigitte has striezak from
the university hospital in bonn thank
you very much for your time
bye-bye